[Music]
time once again for our mornings with
metro segment and today we are joined by
assistant sheriff chavez thank you once
again for joining us this morning sir
thank you
all right metro recently put out a
message about the dangers of fentanyl
and more overdoses you're seeing here in
the valley um
talk about the effort to try and crack
down on this this is a really dangerous
drug in a dangerous situation yes yes in
fact it's a real tragedy we've seen a
200 percent increase in overdoses for
the ages of 18 to 24. and what's
happening is people are expecting to
take oxycodone or hydrocodone which is a
prescription that they would normally
get and then they buy these pills m30s
they're normally stamped on the pills
and they think that that's what they're
taking and in actuality what they're
taking is fentanyl and they take the
same dose and it's such a such a potent
drug it almost kills them instantly
after they ingest it and and it's so
highly addictive too fentanyl it's it's
a it's a an addictive drug you get
hooked on very quickly and it's so
dangerous is it just that there's more
out there is there the black market
that's there what is leading to this
increase in overdoses yeah well it's a
combination of different things but
people get addicted to hydrocodone first
and then they think that they're taking
the same medication and they end up with
fentanyl we actually started the team
with dea and some of our other agencies
an overdose response team to investigate
these deaths because what we try to do
is find out where they coming from who
the dealers are and we've been
successful at charging people for murder
when they're selling when they knowingly
sell uh these fentanyl pills to to to
people who are out there and then they
and then they die yeah it is such a
dangerous situation there
let's switch gears a little bit and talk
about football the las vegas raiders
have their new season starting on monday
we've seen some of the hiccups some of
the hurdles of getting security and the
traffic and people in and out of
allegion stadium smoothly let's talk
about the manpower and what metro is
doing to
get help work with the legion stadium
and get things going smoothly when you
know thousands of people go for the
first home game of course yeah and the
legion stadium is a great partner with
us but uh to run an event like that such
an enormous stadium it's at least 75
officers just on the exterior and our
responsibility is the traffic flow so we
make sure that the lanes are going in
the right direction the traffic is
flowing the right directions parking
that's separate that's a it's private
we still patrol the parking lots make
sure that they're safe but that's not
part of what we do we work with nhp we
work with henderson police and we
partner up to make sure traffic flow in
and out of the stadium is as best as we
can you know i'm trying to think back to
when t-mobile opened
and some of the i know the circumstances
are a little bit different but it is is
it always a little bit um of a work in
progress when a big new venue opens in
las vegas for
for yourself for the venue to all get on
the same page and make things
work smoothly absolutely yeah in fact
we're hoping we've only been i think uh
four major events there legion so far
and it's a it's a work in progress
nobody in vegas has ever seen anything
like this even when t-mobile opened we
struggled a little bit although the the
configurations of parking garages out
there was better uh now uh we're working
with uh with the legion stadiums we're
developing one-way travel lanes we're
working on best ways to to get access uh
and get out of the stadium as well but
it is it's a work in progress john we're
doing the best we can at this point and
hopefully the entire community will
learn along the way we'll get coach
gruden to drop like a game plan or
something
exactly well assistant sheriff thank you
once again for joining us this morning
really i really appreciate it if you
have any questions for metro police
reach out to us on eight news now dot
com